تداول او مواقف مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو للحظه هروب جمل من صاحبه على
طريق سريع بالسعوديه واظهر المقطع الجملي
السائب وهو يجري بين السيارات في طريق
خريص بالرياض وكان الجمل يجري في عكس
الاتجاه ما سبب ارتباكا في حركه المرور
[موسيقى]
ماذا حفلها بالرياض التنمر يلاحق اصاله
كما لاحق هيفاء وهبي بعد ظهوره ظهورها
بملامح غير مالوفه تداول مستخدم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي صور جديده للفنانه
اصاله نصري خلال استعدادها لاحياء حفل
غنائي يوم السبت في مدينه الرياض
بالسعوديه وتعرضت اصاله لانتقادات كثيره
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وعلق البعض
على تغيير ملامحها وبعضهم الاخر قارن
بالموقف مماثل تعرضت له الفنانه اللبنانيه
هيفاء وهبي خلال احيائها حفلا غنائيا في
الرياض ايضا
ميسي ينظف الارض بقميص المكسيك هو ورطه
للنجم الارجنتين وملاكم يتوعده بالضرب
المبرح في مشهد اثار عاصفه غضب الجمهور
المكسيكي بسبب قميص المكسيك المرمي على
الارض تحت ارجل ميسي في غرفه تبديل
الملابس اثناء احتفالات لاعبي الارجنتين
بفوزهم ومن بين الغاضبين بطل العالم في
الملاكمه المكسيكي كان يلو قلبي
على حسابه في تويتر يهدد فيها ميسي كتب
فيها يجب ان يصلي لكي لا اجده اللاعب
الارجنتيني لم يعلق بعد على الواقعه لكننا
مشجعين مشجعينه لا تضعوا عنهم مؤكدين ان
ميسي لم ينتهي لم ينتبه للقميص وكان
متحمسا بالاحتفال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء